I just want me to hit you come on it's
one thing I remember when we first aired
at the Venice Film Festival we had the
best screening ever they do this
midnight screening yeah it was Edward
and I for some reason or not we thought
it'd be a good idea to smoke a joint
beforehand that's right we sat next to
the uh to the guy who was the head of
the festival the movie starts out and
it's dead silent and I see the the
festival ahead I see him start to go
you know with bits that I think are
really funny and everyone I are laughing
out loud we're the only we're like the
obnoxious Americans laughing at our own
movie and there's a particularly
offensive Joe from the Marla character I
haven't been like that since
grade school I thought it was you know
these were going to be rabid cinephiles
and um I think the median age of the
audience was 73. it was dead silent and
we we proceeded to howl even harder and
we had a great experience we thought it
was we were on to something and this
woman looked up and she saw me there and
she recognized and she looked at me and
she just went
I remember you know it always reminds me
of Rocky Horror Picture Show you know
where Susan Sarandon says his muscles
are too big and he says we didn't make
it for you